so
just just a curiosity
if america is building the country that
it's building the founding fathers and
they're going through what they're going
through
you know i applied for a job when i was
21 years old when i got out of the
military and i'm dating a girl who's
working on morgan stanley dean with her
i know nothing about securities stocks
bonds mutual funds nothing i'm a 1.8 gpa
kid
i'm a hummer mechanic this girl's like
hey listen you got to get into financial
services i send my resume to everybody i
have no clue who goldman sachs is at the
time i send my resume do you realize i
wanted to see the reaction of the people
who saw my resume my resume showed
haagen-dazs
bob's big boy burger king military and
ballet total fitness i wish i would pay
money to see the reaction of the hiring
manager that says
what the hell is this guy thinking about
sending a degree
you know a resume like this to us but i
was oblivious goldman would never hire
somebody like me my pedigree my
background who i was so goldman had high
standards
don't you think a country who offers as
much as we do
our filtering system of
who
we we must keep a higher standard to
you know what people have to do to earn
certain things versus trying to please
everybody
yeah i don't know if i can explain this
properly look i'm a byproduct of
immigration that ended up being here and
when we came here we didn't have a lot
to offer i'm thankful for it i'm not
coming from that point of view all i'm
saying is
if if we are from the mindset of
here's everything america offers what
are you bringing to the table okay so
for me i'm like i'm going to pay my debt
off by serving your country okay and i'm
going to pay my debt off to you for
america giving me the opportunity
by
paying a lot of taxes creating jobs and
not having to rely on the government so
taxpayers don't have to help my family
out and i'm just going to be a citizen
that gives back to this country
what happened to the what do you bring
to the table
what happened to what do you bring to
america what happened to what do you
offer us
instead of let's just take everybody
it's like tomorrow goldman sachs
announces and says look
we're offering jobs to everybody we
don't care if you gotta you know
anything we don't care if you got a
background we don't care if you got
anything if you've never had a job
before we're hiring that would be
ludicrous for goldman sachs to announce
something like that if america was
supposed to be that country why do we
drop our standards
and turn it instead of keeping high
standards for people we're almost
begging people to say oh it's okay don't
worry about it let us take care of you
oh it's okay not what are you gonna do
for us when did that shift take place
well uh
i understand i mean this is outside the
immigration policy is not my area of
expertise but i'm familiar with some of
it but it happened in i think in the in
the 60s uh you know when uh
they decided to
uh
broaden
immigration so that would start bringing
in a lot more people from uh you know
from the third world but
i mean i think the real motives behind
it uh were even at the beginning
uh you know a calculation by the
democrat party that they were going to
be the political beneficiaries of
greatly expanded immigration
and um
uh
there were standards there were efforts
to protect the border obviously even as
recently as bill clinton you know was
concerned about uh protect protecting
the borders but we've very quickly
uh had political power taken over in the
democrat party by
uh you know radicals part of this
radical idiot left-wing ideology that
dominates the democrat party today is a
belief in globalism you know they think
uh
and
and the seeds of globalism uh you know
it didn't start with joe biden or or in
recent times but the concept of
globalism really goes uh goes
has a long history
but really a
concept of globalism and
internationalism uh you know uh you know
at least as far back as the aftermath of
world war ii but before that that's why
the united nations was established
that's why we have world court uh you
know that's why we established nato and
then the european union came along uh
you know in academia the not concept of
the nation state got a got a bad
reputation as a consequence of world war
one and world war ii oh nationalism and
patriotism these things result in wars
and uh so we need to create a global
citizen people who identify with a a one
world order you know and go beyond the
nation state and the the league of
nations was an early attempt to do that
uh the united nations
was an attempt to do that
they would never the the elites
and the globalist elites who uh believed
in this philosophy uh
never explained that as the reason to
the american people because that would
be extremely unpopular you know
americans throughout most of our history
have been patriotic and don't think
nationalism is evil and it isn't
uh you know uh uh but we've all we
fought a lot of wars in the name of
globalism all right but we haven't been
explained to us that way that's why the
united states has been all over the
middle east you know engaged in wars
where you were it's almost it's very
hard to find a
an american national interest all right
that is justified for example by the
afghanistan war you know where we've had
people there for a long time so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you